hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well according to Jean
Paul Sartre in existentialism is a
humanism the word humanism itself has
multiple senses and he distinguishes two
main kinds of humanism this is something
that is very important to keep in mind
both generally most philosophical terms
tend to be rather polysemic or ambiguous
like like you know freedom or goodness
or anything like that they don't refer
just to one single thing they don't have
just one sense and humanism is a word
like that as well it's very important
not to blur different kinds of humanism
in to each other to conflate them to
assume that there's just one thing out
there that's actually going by that term
and so Sartre is actually addressing
some of his critics who said listen in
one of your early novels nausea you said
the humanists were all wrong you made
fun of a certain kind of humanist why
come back to humanism now I assume this
name for yourself and the movement of
philosophy that you're advocating and
Sartre has a good response he says
listen I
understand that there's all sorts of
things going by this name humanism
here's how existentialist humanism is
different from them so we have as he
says theories that take humanity as an
end and as a higher value and we'll talk
about that in just a moment and as
opposed to them
we have existentialist views on humanity
why does humanism arise well humanism is
in part a reaction against things that
would devalue the human that would say
that human beings really don't matter
that much so you could think of although
there are religious humanists humanism
was often a reaction particularly in
Sartre zone time and the centuries
preceding it against religious ways of
looking at things that said listen God
or the gods or whatever created the
human beings they have to obey his or
her whenever's rules and that's it
as a matter of fact if you go back to
some conceptions of mythological
conceptions the human beings were
actually created to be the slaves of the
gods right or maybe there's some people
who get to enjoy full freedom because
they're close to the gods humanism says
no no no no what matters is the human
being now the key question then is how
should we conceptualize the human being
and so Sartre talks about what we could
call a certain kind of essentialist
humanism and I'm just using that term in
a very broad sense meaning any kinds of
humanism that think that there is an
essential human nature a claim that
Sartre himself
contests and he's got this great example
here he says that humanism in this sense
can be found in Cocteau Hale around the
world in 80 hours when a character
because he's flying over some mountains
in an airplane declares man is simply
amazing and he says what's going on
there let's analyze this let's think
about this what that means is that I
find the person who's putting myself in
this characters place
as a human being we'll personally
consider myself responsible for and
honored by acts of a few particular
people so this means that we ascribe a
value to human being on the basis of the
highest deeds of certain people and he
says that this is actually absurd and
his his own argument for this is a
little bit funny he says that this is
absurd because in order to make a
judgment like that you would need to be
only a dog or a horse which they're
careful not to do at least to my
knowledge he's making a little bit of a
joke for his audience but if you think
about what's going on there we're taking
a tiny little section of humanity and
saying this is what humanity really is
you know the best parts of ourselves and
we do this in speech after speech after
speech think about when there's a
national tragedy and some people respond
to it well they get medals and you know
the President or the governor whoever
gives a big speech about these people
are heroes and they represent the best
in inhumanity and can't we all be like
them and Sartre says that's not all
there is to humanity so let's not
glorify these highest parts right now
you know in a certain respect that kind
of makes sense if you do think that
there is a genuine human nature these
people perhaps realized it or realized
it more than the rest of us do right
they unveiled its potentials and brought
them to reality but Sartre would say
human being is way more open than that I
mean we have the potentials for great
goodness and we have the potentials for
great badness as well you know and you
can even look at other philosophers who
did believe there is a human nature and
see that Aristotle for example says
human beings when they're you know doing
good are the best of all creatures but
they're the worst when they're bad when
they're vicious right so we have these
wide range of potentialities within us
and there's the assumption of their be
you know some sort of general human
nature that maybe didn't come from us
from God but the sciences will reveal to
us and Sartre says no that's not the
case he also goes on and he says here we
go let us not also believe there's a
mankind to which we might set up a cult
in the matter of a ghost cult the cult
of mankind ends in the self-enclosed
humanism of compt and let it be said of
fascism this kind of humanism we can do
without what a cult seek to do cult one
of the early sociologists as a matter of
fact one of the fathers of that
discipline and a big proponent of what
we call positivism not logical
positivism but the positivism that
preceded that more narrow type compt
thought that we needed to get out get
rid of all the mythological theological
conceptions of things as a matter of
fact we too need to move beyond
philosophy and get to a purely
positivist way of looking at things and
then along with this this very
scientific rationalistic way of looking
at things he also said we need to make
humanity into the object of religious
adoration and he basically just cribbed
things from the Catholic Church putting
humanity in the place of God not the
only person to do so at the time by the
way and said okay this is what we're
going to propose Sartre says that's a
terrible terrible idea we need to
actually get away from worshipping
anything and think about humanity and
the full range of the values that we can
take on so how does existentialist
humanism look different he says well
fundamentally the basis for this is a
metaphysical basis human beings are
constantly outside of themselves in
projecting themselves in losing
themselves outside of themselves the
person makes for Humanity's existing and
I'm he says on the other hand that's one
side of it it is in pursuing
transcendent goals that
person is able to exist so we are two
things at the same time where this
continual flow of existence going beyond
ourselves exceeding ourselves surpassing
ourselves never staying quite the same
and we orient ourselves by transcendent
goals those transcendent cult goals
could include things that are vital to
humanity as well so he says it's by
pursuing these transcendent goals were
able to be what we are seizing upon
things only as they bear upon this
passing beyond is at the heart at the
center of this passing beyond what does
all this metaphysical language mean we
choose we choose for ourselves and
determinate circumstances and thereby
determine what Humanity is for ourselves
and perhaps also for others if they take
up the uses of freedom that we ourselves
exercised there is no pre given human
nature there is no grand plan we get to
decide what humanity is going to look
like so humanism rather than simply
being a you know switch of allegiance
from God to humanity or you know the God
to the sciences or whatever you want
winds up being an exercise of human
freedom that directs that freedom
towards honoring warning about
understanding that very human freedom
that's what humanism would mean for
Sartre
he says going on with this there is no
universe other than a human universe
it's not like we're going to start with
the sciences with human beings abstract
it out from it this is what we've got
there is no universe other than the
universe of human subjectivity says and
he says human beings are not closed in
on themselves but they're always present
in a human universe this is what we call
existentialist Hugh
so he says humanism why because we
remind people there is no lawmaker other
than humanity itself themselves the
person others ourselves we are the
lawmakers we are the deciders we are the
ones who form and follow and recognize
moral norms they aren't imposed on us
from outside they don't come up from our
biology or our chemistry or anything
like that they're not there because some
transcendent creator wove them into the
structure of the universe they are there
because we on some level choose to find
them they're not as if you know we
completely make them up out of whole
cloth as we say but we take what's
coming in from the rest of the universe
and we interpret it so he says we we are
also stuck in for Lorna's we will decide
by ourselves and we point out that the
human being will fulfill him or herself
as a human being not in turning towards
themselves but seeking outside of
themselves a goal which is just this
liberation just this particular
fulfillment
so our existence is that in a human
universe and we bear a responsibility
for our decisions and inescapable
unavoidable responsibilities cert takes
all of that to be of the essence of any
sort of genuine existentialist humanism
there is one other thing I should say as
we bring this little discussion of
humanism to a close not all
existentialists not all people within
the broad spectrum of what we call
existentialism as a movement accepted
this as a matter of fact Martin
Heidegger was willing to let Sartre take
up the name existentialism precisely
over this doctrine Heidegger does not
want his philosophy to be humanistic in
the way that sart's is we might say that
Nietzsche is also not
humanists in this respect as well and
perhaps Kierkegaard is not either it's
kind of an open question how well Sartre
manages to represent existentialism per
se rather than just his particular brand
of existentialism but be that as it may
this is his understanding of what
humanism could mean to different senses
of the term often at odds with each
other
you